what up space fam golson here from anime
up we're back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one piece story this was an amazing
chapter that we've been waiting for for
a long time it includes more of zoro's
backstory king's identity endless secret
and much more so make sure to stay tuned
for this goosebumps inducing chapter if
you do enjoy seeing these one-piece
reviews and want to keep them coming you
know what to do channel the pirate king
with it and smash that like button with
no mercy as we all know smashing that
like button is pirate king energy and
passing is orochi energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one-piece videos and updates
that's just the way it works and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my huge and
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos on all the yonko admiral
supernova and much more link to that is
in the description now without further
ado let's jump into it spoilers and all
this chapter is called shimotsuki
kozaburo who was the master swordsman
who crafted enma and wado ichimonji aka
the blade zoro god from kuina kozabura
was also sensei koshiro's father and
kuina's grandfather since most of us
have good reason to believe that zoro is
related to shimotsuki aruma and is even
the son of shimotsuki ushimaru it
suggests that all these shimotsuki are
related thus it seems even more fitting
for koshiro to entrust kuina's rare
blade to zorro as he did anyways all
this stuff is fascinating it's so
awesome to be getting this info about
kuina koshiro and wado ichimonji after
more than 1000 chapters sometimes you
forget to focus on the character's
origins so i love it when the story
brings it back into focus like this
after so much time but back to the king
vs zorro fight enma is draining energy
from zoro without his permission it's
pretty clear already that enma will be
the key to the victory in this fight but
before that zorro has to figure out how
to actually use it to its full potential
king's comments are hilarious too as he
asks zoro trouble in paradise it is
strange to see a source swordsman
quarreling with his sword and king will
definitely bring that up more in this
chapter but a common theme we're seeing
in one piece recently is that the best
swords are more like partners to the
swordsmen rather than just dead tools
and although in the short term king's
blade seems much simpler to use and more
effective enma's difficulty of use will
no doubt correlate with greater
potential down the line for now though
zoro stabs king king has the best
reaction ever saying ah a direct hit
not worried at all then he appears to
explode and we jump to sanji really it's
not so much about sanji's fight here as
it's about giving us more information
about zorro and king queen confirms that
king is in fact the surviving lunarian
he tells us they were all supposed to be
eradicated he comments that those
monsters as he calls them could thrive
in any inhospitable environment the
world threw at them people like that may
even be able to survive on the moon as
their name suggests queen even says they
were considered gods in the past and i'm
glad sanji actually asked the question
we're probably all wondering how come
they're so op and yet they got
eradicated but queen says as if oda
himself is teasing us through queen
that's something you'll have to find out
for yourself that's yet another thing
i'm super curious about but for now
within that story there is a suggestion
that king can obviously be defeated by
zorro if almost all of the godlike
people were wiped out if i had to guess
i'd assume that it was the world
government in a coordinated effort and
perhaps with a surprise attack that
wiped them out but we shall see whoever
did it must have found the weakness that
lunarians have and that zorro is looking
for back to the main event with the
zorro and king battle not only is king
fine after the stab and subsequent
explosion zorro is the one on the ropes
for a moment thinking he'd be a goner if
used armament even a second later zoro
is surprised that king is unscathed
after blowing himself up but still
attacks using lethal lion's song
according to him one of his strongest
techniques it literally looks like it
had no effect at all on king and king
then moves into attack zorro actually
gets hurt because enma started acting
out and distracting him the cliff below
him straight up falls apart thanks to
king's attack and zoro proceeds to fall
once again king insults and teases him
saying a swordsman beaten by his own
sword that's a first so for now the
battle hasn't begun for real in a sense
because zoro hasn't synced up with enma
instead of working together it's more
like enva's getting in the way however
what zoro was saying before in the
previous chapter about needing to know
the race of king before he can beat him
actually makes more sense after what
we've seen in this chapter for some
reason king seems completely unaffected
by normal attacks and it stands to
reason that lunarians have a special
weakness to counterbalance their
overpoweredness finally we got a fight
where zoro will need to push beyond his
current limits to win it feels like it's
been a while since he had to do that so
i'm super excited to see what that looks
like for now though as zoro is grabbing
his swords in midair he experiences some
flashbacks he grabs sandai kitatsu which
was said to be a cursed blade originally
in the meantime king kicks him insulting
him for risking himself to save a sword
however as i mentioned swords have wills
of their own in this series at least the
op ones and chances are they'll pay
zorro back for this loyalty that looks
completely illogical to king next he
reaches out for wado ichimonji the sword
he got from kuina thinking it's a relief
it didn't fall off the island we get a
flashback to way back near the beginning
of the series when zoro begged kuina's
father for her sword and promises that
he'll get strong enough that his name
reaches up to the heavens and that he'll
become the greatest swordsman for
himself and for her i've been saying
this is and is going to continue to be a
heavily zoro focused arc and having this
flashback back to his origin only
solidifies that i also like the mention
of reaching up to the heavens since it's
a nice contrast with enma named after
the god of the underworld pretty much at
the end of the series you know zoro's
going to be saying we started from the
bottom that we hear we then get back to
zorro speaking to swordsmith tenguyama
hitetsu in the past and the latter
telling him it must be fate that zorro
gets enma because enma and wado
ichimonji were forged by the same man
the master swordsmith shimotsuki
kozaburo and yes he just said the title
of the chapter zorro finally starts
connecting the dots and thinking about
how a sword from wano ended up in the
east blue king continues the attack
onslaught and zoro is clearly on the
defensive as the flashbacks continue the
tsunachi convo with momo is brought up
when zoro said he heard it from an old
geezer even though he never used it
himself he never learned the geezer's
name which is pretty hilarious but he
sat by the shore a lot he only found out
this geezer was queen as grandpa after
he died he puts that back together with
hitetsu telling him that kozaburro left
the country illegally over 50 years ago
then we get a flashback all the way back
to when zoro was a kid brand new stuff
and i gotta say i've been waiting
forever for this 13 years ago in
shimotsuki village the geezer tells zoro
that tsunachi is a battle cry that gives
one courage but hilariously zoro says he
won't use it since it sounds weird he's
such a classic annoying kid here and
it's hilarious to see he asks the geezer
if he was a samurai and the geezer
responds that zoro should be quiet or
the marines will come for him they
exchange insults but the geezer whose
look is just amazing i must say takes
note of zorro's energy and how hard he
trains zoro at one point tells the
geezer he lost to kuina so he needs to
train non-stop not just in the dojo the
geezer gives him two real swords even
though zoro has no money so there we
have yet another epic and rude old dude
with a heart of gold in one piece the
geezer goes on to imply that these
swords aren't as special as his old ones
and proceeds to educate us about swords
like we've been saying each blade is
like a person with a unique disposition
not just dead tools a swordsman is one
who tames the sword's wild nature and
bends it to their will and here we get a
cool moment where zoro's told it's a
joke when people say swords are cursed
it's just how name blades are it's
praise rather than anything else they
fulfill their purpose of taking life and
this explains why zoro was so undaunted
by the fact that his sword was set to be
cursed it's a really nice touch and i'm
glad we got it in this chapter klosaburo
tells zorro he crafted his magnum opus
aka his masterpiece when he was still
young the temperament of the sword was
something else it would give chills to
those holding it he named it after the
lord of the underworld and zorro finally
realizes that that sword is the sword in
front of him aka enma this backstory
mid-fight was masterfully done i love
the backstory itself but it was also
perfect for adding significance to this
fight and to enma specifically the
implication is the more problematic the
sword like enma the better it is when
one can finally sync up with it and that
is the task set before zorro gotta also
say i absolutely love this old dude
kozaburo is a boss finally zoro realizes
that his village being called shimotsuki
doesn't seem like a coincidence anymore
he finally says that that old geezer was
a samurai wano specifically the
swordsmith shimotsuki kozaburo and as he
says this all i can think is imagine how
hilarious it would be if zoro had
sherlock holmes job but lastly he
remembers being told that named blades
stay vigilant patiently waiting to find
a swordsman worthy of them and that a
sword chooses its wielder and zoro
realizes that enma is just testing him
it's not resisting him or acting out of
malice zorro just hasn't been measuring
up to its standards and he is odd that
odin was easily able to wield enma with
this much haki pouring out of him love
the look of the black and enma 2 in this
panel the implication is that zoro once
mastering anima will be near odin level
or at least a lot closer to it which is
hype since we know what odin did to
kaido albeit to a younger kaido at the
very least i think it's safe to say
it'll be enough to beat king then as
underlings tried to rush zorro his
conqueror's haki causes them to faint
always cool seeing zoro use conquerors
haki zoro remarks that he can only
appease enma with all of his hockey and
that could kill him but as we know
zoro's never been one to shy away from
situations that could kill him in fact
he goes through them and says nothing
happened i really like this aspect it
wasn't about him needing to tame enma
per se but about enma forcing him to
step up and go beyond what he thought
would be possible as we see zoro all his
blades are burning overflowing with haki
and king sees that he has kingly
ambitions as well which is pretty much a
way of saying he's got conquerors haki
and just to top off this beautiful
chapter my favorite in a while zoro
thinks of his meeting with luffy way
back then luffy said the future king of
the pirates would settle for nothing
less than the world's greatest swordsman
zorro tells king i guess you're right
after all i made promises to my captain
and my oldest friend thus were reminded
of what makes zorro tick the promise he
made to queena to luffy and his own
desire to be the best swordsman in the
world we're told zoro is surpassing
limits which is hype since it is pretty
much confirming that zorro just became
and is becoming the strongest he's ever
been this might be my favorite zorro
focus chapter yet but let me know if
there's one you prefer more obviously
zorro has had many great moments but the
way they tied up his backstory here and
had him reaffirm his goal with the new
power up it's just too good i won't even
ask you who was mvp here because it's
obviously zorro although i would also
accept enma as an answer since swords
are practically living characters at
this point and that is it for as i said
one of my favorite chapters in a while i
loved it let me know what you thought
about it and what you're expecting to
see happening next will zorro crush king
suddenly or will we get more back and
forth moments as zoro's power continues
to increase if you did enjoy this review
and want to keep them coming you know
what to do channel the pirate king
within and smash that like button with
no mercy as we all know smashing that
like button is pirating energy and
passing is orochi energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates that's just
the way it works and while you wait for
the next chapter to drop feel free to
check out my huge and growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on all
yonko admirals supernova and much more
link to that is in the description and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
so
[Music]
you